als gedacht und herzlich willkommen
stöger video ich hoffe natürlich jedes
mobile haben sich gewöhnen alex warum
machst du nicht mehr diese schulen
essens videos wie früher ich weiß ich
hab vor einem halben jahr oder so schon
mal wieder 23 essen gemacht aber das war
es dann auch wieder ich kann euch jetzt
versprechen ich habe auch schon ein paar
weitere vorproduziert das ist jetzt das
erste weil ich finde so kann man wieder
gut rein staaten ab jetzt gibt es jede
woche auch ein essens video und dann
halt wenn ich schaffe auch ein anderes
video also unboxing mich irgendwie sowas
wie hält die videos die er sonst von mir
gewohnt sein und ja wir starten heute in
meiner heimatstadt das ist eine
kleinstadt aber trotzdem gibt es etwas
neues war sehr sehr schlecht ist ich
muss fairerweise sagen wir haben jetzt
schon viele nach all das ist auch das
einzige was jetzt noch liefert aber die
lieferung bis 3 uhr die kommen jetzt
auch nicht konkret aus meiner
heimatstadt sondern so eine andere stadt
die hier neben dran ist aber trotzdem
kann ich sagen hier testen heute das
schlechteste essen was ich hier und hier
nach hause bestellen kann nur die
nächsten part die folgen aus düsseldorf
da war ich nämlich letzten ich bin echt
gespannt weil ich habe mir schon ein
paar rezensionen durchlesen wir machen
das jetzt zusammen sofort auch noch mal
und dann schauen wir mal wie lange es
dauert und ob die heute nacht noch
ankommt leute also merkt euch das einmal
die woche kommt jetzt auch alex liegen
lernen essens video ich hoffe dass das
nice und wir bestellen jetzt okay leute
ich bin ja jetzt hose deswegen dachte
ich mir kurz meine aufnahme ecke für
mainz weit kanal und in diesem zimmer
ist es nach wie vor sei es deswegen
wundert euch nicht schauen uns mal die
bewertung an wo ich euch ja schon
vorgewarnt habe dass sie wirklich
schlecht sind und ich glaube auch nicht
dass ich euch jetzt direkt zeige wie das
restaurant heiß oder ist euch überhaupt
zeigen weil ich will natürlich auch
niemanden irgendwie bloßstellen wir
schauen uns hier direkt weil die
bewertungen an und ich muss sagen so was
vor das ist wirklich schlecht wir haben
hier tatsächlich 1067 bewertungen und
nur 2,9 sterne also super super viele
menschen waren schon richtig unzufrieden
wie zum beispiel der peter hier sehr
unzufrieden auch mit der kommunikation
gibt eine nummer an aber wisst
anscheinend nicht wie man benutzt ich
habe echt wieder bock auf sowas naja
also guck mal wenn ich hier runter
scrollen
hier ist wirklich essen alles über allen
ein stern okay hier haben wir auch mal
einen mit vier sternen essener top
geschmeckt und der lieferant war sehr
nett und hat mir ein getränk geschenkt
weil er ein paar minuten später kann
alles in einem top laden nix tolles
pizza sehr trocken wenig käse gibt
schlimmeres aber auch wesentlich
besseres in lippe also da wohne ich
nicht aber die liefern und ein bisschen
schön lange gewartet aber der scam berg
halte es macht ist dass wer hat für nur
15 euro gab es einen minderwertigen
bürger und festhalten bitte ganze 15
bommels also man kann ja von einer
portion of its leben war echt also oder
auch hier der nächste kommentar einfach
kurz und knackig hatte
pitzer leider überhaupt nicht lecker der
käse welcher ja normalerweise goldgelb
weiß auf einer pizza sichtbar ist ist
überhaupt nicht sicher auf der pizza
stattdessen nur irgend ein
durchsichtiger fed belag reise für die
leistung geradezu unverschämt ich glaube
ich habe auch ein mindestbestellwert von
irgendwie 55 euro dennoch gibt es
vereinzelnd trotzdem auch zum beispiel
hier auch viel positives feedback aber
jetzt in letzter zeit halt nicht mehr so
wie weswegen leute ich bin gespannt und
ich würde sagen hier bestellen jetzt mal
ja gesagt der burger war nicht gut wobei
ich jetzt hier nun bürger für 8 euro 50
sehe anschein wortes geändert den
bestellen wir einfach mal mit coca cola
also das ist ja wirklich preiswert
vielleicht haben die ja die ganzen
rezension gelesen und sich ein bisschen
was zu herzen genommen so dann schauen
wir mal ja insalata die promotoren
insalata mister ich wollte erst unser
land bestellen aber dann habe ich hier
die kartoffelgerichte gesehen kartoffel
mozzarella grad hängen also das klingt
doch wirklich lecker das kaufe ich auch
okay aber schon noch bei 19 euro da
müssen wir leider noch ein bisschen was
drauf packen wir sind jetzt hier
mittlerweile bei den pizzen es ist ja
auch ein italienisches restaurant so
gesehen und da muss ich natürlich jetzt
auch eine pizza bestellen pizza
margarita mit knoblauch steht hier das
ist ja interessant es hieß ja der käse
ist einfach nur klebrig fertig oder so
er kommt dann nehmen wir jetzt die
margarita wo ich ein bisschen größer und
höher doch ist er jetzt auf oder wie ich
will aber keinen knoblauch darauf mit
käse rand der käse rand wurde auch
ordentlich gefordert in den kommentaren
deswegen kauft man das einfach mal und
jetzt leute wir haben es gleich wir
haben uns gleich was habe ich dann noch
gesehen kann das eh nicht alleine essen
entweder ist überzeugt mich dann esse
ich es halt dann morgen auf oder wenn
man es nicht genießen kann was wir auch
schon oft hatten in den schlechtesten
restaurants folgen dann ist es natürlich
sehr schade aber dann esse ich es auch
nicht dass hier fand ich auch noch
interessant calamari fred i mit
frittierten tintenfischringe und salat
und knoblauchsoße weniger schnitzel
wiener art wir haben auch wirklich alles
mit chicken nuggets was ist denn mit
getränken kann ich hier keine getränke
bestellen die haben ja nicht mal
getränke das ja schade das muss ich mir
noch irgendwas zusammen suchen hier ja
komm passt auf wir haben hier noch ein
paar löffel teller dazu und hier so ein
paar tipps süß saurer soße knoblauchsoße
honig soße leicht charolais kommen das
reicht so jetzt haben wir's wird
bestellt und dann sehen wir uns wieder
wenn es ankommt ich hoffe das passiert
auch diese nachhaltig habe bei der nacht
bekommen von lieferando.de einer
bestellung bei wird in circa 59 minuten
geliefert also wir haben jetzt gerade 23
uhr 24 das heißt der ganze spaß wäre
dann um 0 uhr 23 da wir warten jetzt
einfach mal ganz entspannt und ich freue
mich aufs essen weil ich muss sagen ich
habe extra nicht so viel zu abend
gegessen um das jetzt noch durchführen
zu können ich melde mich bis gleich
alles klar ich habe versucht die kann
man aufpassen an zu machen die kollegen
haben mich gerade angerufen und leiten
die calamari sich ja noch gestellt da
schon ausverkauft und ich habe jetzt
aber die scampis bekommen die kosten 15
euro im gleichen preis von zwölf euro
trifft zwar nicht so bock auf sowas aber
ich will jetzt auch nicht so groß rum er
kann ich meinen so etwas kann immer mal
passieren in jedem restaurant institut
hat sich aber eigentlich ganz so
angehört und das ist ja dann auch das
zeichen dafür nicht so wie in der
eigenen rezension dass das telefon nicht
geht anscheinend geht es ja doch und
eine sache die mir noch wichtig war zu
sagen und zwar wenn ich jetzt in anderen
städten bei den großstädten dann ist mir
das natürlich scheißegal und ich zeige
dir auch die namen von jeglichen
restaurants nur hier bei mir in der
heimatstadt wo jeder jeden kennt das
finde ich ein bisschen schwierig und
deswegen bleibt das glaube ich besser
zensiert ich hoffe das könnt ihr
verstehen es sei denn es wird es
unfassbar lecker aber ja ich bin
gespannt achtung jetzt fällt mir gerade
auf ich habe schon so ewig mich zwei
hingestellt meine klingel zu hause ist
defekt geht einfach nicht mehr weiß ich
hoffe die bereits rufen mich einfach
anwenden da sind oder der vielleicht
seine frau über sie so leute ich habe
schon alles aufgebaut und ich warte
sehnsüchtig aufs essen wir haben
mittlerweile schon 0 50 also wenn die
kollegen schon eine halbe schon zu spät
und ich bin auch langsam ein bisschen
müde gucken wir doch mal draußen müsste
man jetzt mal kommen muss ich da noch
mal an hier leute etwas da wo danke ciao
oder mahlzeit jetzt hier 123 geil ich
habe sogar eine cola dazu bekommen
obwohl die eigentlich gar keine kohle
hatten also zumindest nicht weil
lieferanten
ja bin ich mal gespannt das ist ja
wirklich mehr als genug dieses rohr
sonne papier das erinnert mich einmal in
echt leckere sachen weil früher hatten
wir so ein imbiss den gibt es da nicht
mehr und die haben ihre sachen auch
immer so eingepackt messer gabel kann
man so gebraucht der fahrer aber auf
jeden fall sehr sehr nett und wenn ich
mal gespannt wer jetzt weiß ich warum
der salat dabei ist genau der war
nämlich bei den calamari oder bei den
scampis jetzt dabei und dann haben wir
hier einmal den salat macht finde ich im
guten abend dem beschlagen sieht das aus
eigentlich nicht schlecht eine cola zero
zwei mal süß saurer soße das ist dann
wahrscheinlich die große wir haben hier
macht also den wärmsten eindruck das
kartoffelgratin wir arbeiten uns einfach
mal chronologisch durch wo sie den salat
aus leute ich würde sagen eigentlich
ganz gut probiere ich mal kann ja auch
nicht so viel falsch machen uns jetzt
auch nicht meist bei ist einfach ein
gemischter knackiger salat ohne dressing
ich bin halt nicht so der salat sein
also habe er auch eingestellt eigentlich
schmeckt erfrischend gut aber erst mal
zur seite wir auch in beilagen zu
salaten und ist das hier so langsam ran
kommen wir doch einfach mal zudem
weiß ich jetzt nicht ihr wisst ja ich
bin sowieso sehr empfindlich ich bin
einfach so es tut mir leid das hier ist
jetzt das paradies schlechtesten
restaurants das ist immer so eine sache
für sich da habe ich immer einfach
probleme hat erstmal braucht jetzt ein
deckchen was sich nämlich ganz schön ich
finde ist dieser saft der da links
runter gelaufen ist also eigentlich
sieht es ja ganz lecker aus aber das
hier dieser saft und in der ecke keine
ahnung ist irgendwie ein bisschen
fraglich es soll jetzt das kartoffel
tings sein
nein es sind die scampis warum kriege
ich denn nicht einfach carli marie naja
kann probier mal einfach mal
[Musik]
ich muss fairerweise sagen schmeckt in
ordnung auch wenn der anblick dieses
gerichts nicht so gut ist sehr wichtig
aber gut ist ja klar ne also die cola
von denen ist super das ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich wirklich hier das
kartoffelgratin auch schon diese
komischen ränder aber bei
kartoffelgratin kann man jetzt glaube
ich nicht so viel falsch machen und auch
mal rein die hast halt auch schon diesen
ganzen saft dran was ist denn los mit
denen also das ist nicht normal torleute
aber so sieht es aus ich muss sagen
probieren wir einfach machen wir haben
eine kartoffel mit mozzarella war das ja
relativ kalten kartoffel schneidgut
fehlte dazu
tomaten sind auch drin und wünscht sich
jetzt nicht aber gut weiß nicht ob ich
dir drin schon feier vertrag mit dem
käse kann man gut
also das kartoffelgratin schmeckt mir
auf jeden fall deutlich besser als die
scampis ist halt generell finde ich eine
beilage ich habe schon deutlich besseres
kartoffelgratin gegessen ich weiß nicht
ob ich schon mal leichteres
kartoffelgratin gegessen hat eigentlich
das immer nur bei meiner mama oder im
restaurant aber so liefern mäßig ist das
vollkommen solide deswegen habe ich hier
kein einwand kommen wir zum nächsten
produkt sorry leute mikrofon ist
abgehakt wir haben als nächstes jahr
pizza brot hab das jetzt schon mal
getestet das ganze wurde geliefert mit
knoblauch tipp aber es ist ja auch gut
wenn ihr ton habe deswegen jetzt noch
mal kann man auf jeden fall gut
genüsslich eintauchen und dann
köstlich schmächtig ist
die waren bestimmt jetzt auch eine halbe
stunde unterwegs sind dann hat er es
nicht gefunden meinte funktioniert und
so ein bisschen punkig aber okay will
ich gar nichts sagen der knoblauch wobei
eigentlich ist dass der cocktail an ich
weiß es ich habe mir den honig senf tipp
genommen kann man auf jeden fall auch
essen haut mich um den nicht wahr ich
habe gerade auch schon ein stück pizza
gegessen aber dann ist mir aufgefallen
dass das mikrofon raus war deswegen wird
jetzt erst mal im bayern kasten also es
könnte halt alles ahs könnte alles ein
bisschen wärmer sein aber das finde ich
aber gut gemacht wird mag das auch so
richtig wie in einer richtigen preis
wurde auch schon relativ kalt sieht auf
jeden fall aus wie einem guten
bürgerladen das beruhigt mich schon mal
wobei wir schauen wir uns vielleicht mal
an die gleich ob sie dabei ist aber mit
bürgern kenne mich aus und sorry catch a
fire nicht dabei bin muss ich denn jetzt
mal hier drauf machen bei ketchup gehört
auch zu pommes dazu haben wir ein
crashtest mit
weniger quatsch ich also bis auf den
salat ist das jetzt nicht alles so super
frische berger let's check dauert
maximal hier vorne für euch aus ist auf
jeden fall ein solider großer burger hat
ja auch nur 8 euro 50 gekostet aber was
ich mir jetzt gerade frage ist hier tost
sie drauf oder was ist das
das ist ja wirklich eine frechheit
standards dabei und ich bin dumm es das
überhaupt materie ist schicken
wahrscheinlich ne und guckt euch das man
kann nach hin die besten restaurants
testen das ist auf jeden fall mehr mein
fall weiß gar nicht ob das überhaupt
fleisch ist und hier steht aber nichts
von chicken naja egal also da würde ich
mich auf jeden fall als kunde aufregen
wenn ich da jetzt vorbestellt hätte so
halt um einfach satt zu werden wir haben
jetzt dicke gurkenscheiben bei also die
panade vom schicken oder toast die was
auch immer das ist deshalb schon so
aufgeweicht also ich verstehe wirklich
nicht warum nennt ihr das dann nicht
einfach schicken bürger dann würdet ihr
jedem gefallen mittun okay ich probiere
aber mal
noch eine bombe sind daher also so leid
es mir tut ich wünschte ich könnte etwas
positives sagen aber für mich ist es
ungenießbar ich weiß ich bin vielleicht
ein bisschen penibler als andere food
youtuber die sagen dann ist okay kann
man essen der geist wird mich so
aufregen wenn ich das bestellen hätte
also das ist definitiv der schlechteste
dickenberger den ich je in meinem leben
gegessen habe ja es wirklich schade und
die pommes sind in ordnung wäre besser
aus als sie schmecken zu guter letzt wir
jetzt nur noch hier die margherita
bitzer von der ich aber auch schon mal
ein stück probiert habe dies aber auf
jeden fall solide ich kann auf jeden
fall verstehen dass leute kommentiert
haben der pizzabelag sei ein bisschen
aus wie klebriges fed aber schmecken
tut's vielleicht hier mit dem club
auf jeden fall nicht die pizza und das
kartoffelgratin solide kann man gut
essen alles andere und vor allem der
bürger waren lisa flop aber ich habe ich
die zürcher so sind ganz vergessen naja
egal ich tue ich in meinem kühlschrank
so ich habe auf jeden fall jetzt alles
mal probiert keine sorge die pizza wird
auf jeden fall noch aufwärts und
kartoffelgratin auch hat sich ist das
restaurant hat mich überhaupt nicht
überzeugt dass ich wirklich so schlecht
ist in den rezensionen stehen aber ihr
könnt euch vorhin auf die nächsten
folgen aus düsseldorf und ich glaube das
wird noch mal besser weil da ist einfach
die auswahl viel größer und ja meine
heimatstadt ist halt was kulinarische
vielfalt an geht bei mir wohl nur 50.000
einem monat absolut für eine art stark
fürs zuschauen leute wir sehen uns haut
rein